oh my God I'm so excited okay hold on
I'm gonna like a sick weirdo I'm like
let's I'm Gonna Save it all for the
taping
um hold on okay I'm gonna get started
and jump in you ready I'm ready all
right
[Music]
welcome back to the Drew's News podcast
where we're giving you all the fun
quirky and inspiring informative stories
that exist out in the world today we're
covering everything from Drake shading
Serena Williams hubby to inside Selena
Gomez's birthday wedding party and we're
doing it with a very special guest I'm
not gonna lie I'm really like excited I
I I just I I can't wait to pick the mind
and the brain of someone who has really
come onto the scene and sort of changed
it as we know it let's just say he or
she runs a very popular IG account where
all the tea is dropped they have a new
novel out entitled a non please
please welcome it's dumwa
hi I'm so excited to be here I'm a huge
fan
I love you so much and it's amazing huge
fan too as far as I think it's probably
the business side of me that is you know
one aspect of many that is so fascinated
by what you've managed to accomplish in
the world
um I just how did you get the idea to
start this Anonymous account I'm curious
about the name the graphics like how
what was the the spark that led to the
fire well
it's not that exciting it's much more
exciting in the book I will say that in
the book The fictionalized version of
how it went down is much more exciting
in reality it was during quarantine and
I was home in my apartment
um ordered to stay home like much of New
York I live in New York City and I was
scared and I didn't know what was gonna
happen in my future and as a way to
distract myself from everything that was
going on in the world
um I took this account it was an account
that was a defunct account that started
in 2013 as sort of like a fashion
lifestyle blog account
um it hadn't been used really in years
and I took to the account it had about
35 000 followers none of who I even knew
if they still follow the account because
it wasn't really active and I said to
everyone
submit any celebrity encounters that you
guys have had like throughout your life
it wasn't even anything that needed to
be current it was like just submit
anything that you've encountered with
celebrities and I'll post it for us to
read because we're all stuck at home and
you know we're kind of all in this
together and that's literally how it
started can I add that day did you use
the word encounters yeah I think I just
said like if any of you guys have ever
met a celebrity or encountered a
celebrity
um you know write in and I'll post it
and the first story I got was about
Leonardo Dicaprio and I think there was
actually one about there was one about
you also oh that was in the first wave
somebody saw you in an airport I think
somebody had saw you in an airport
um it was a positive encounter I mean
every single Drew Barrymore counter has
been positive and you've always been
like super welcoming like I've had
stories people submit of meeting you at
like a restaurant at a bar like
strangers and you just like sitting down
and like having a chat and having a
drink it's like I I don't know how you
do it well one of the most welcoming
celebrities I'm that means so much to me
that's the real me like that's much more
me but I do have a rebellion I mean I
was institutionalized I've been a bad
girl like I do have that streak in me
I'm an alley cat but the much more true
to me is yeah every human encounter is a
chance to make a positive exchange and I
don't really understand why anyone would
do it differently I know everybody has
their moments but you could still be
human if you're going through a moment
and still make it okay at the end of the
day there's just no excuse for rude bad
behavior in my opinion and by the way if
you do that's probably going to bring
out my Scrappy side like if you're a
straight up jerk and it it you know it
might get a rise in me
um but for the most part I'm just really
positive the reason I even chose is the
word encounter and I zeroed in on that
because that to me has such a different
tone than like gossip like gossip almost
invites in sort of a trolley toxicity
whereas the word encounter is so smart
and interesting because that already
sets a different sort of
entree if you will into the information
it's it's interesting that you chose
that word yes the word it was never
gossip in the beginning I think it sort
of you know the account has changed also
like in the past two and a half years
but in the beginning it was just like
let's just share stories with each other
about celebrities and then it kind of
also turned into like let's get to know
our favorite celebrities better like
what are they like in real life you know
like the the waiter the waitress the car
driver the hotel concierge like everyone
was chiming in about like their
encounters with celebrities and it kind
of you know I I don't know I almost felt
like a like celebrity therapist like
people were even like writing in like
bad encounters and I I would have to be
like wow I'm like really sorry you went
through that like maybe they were having
a bad day
um but yeah it was just like a way to
get to know your favorite celebrity
better like in a more real way that had
ever been pushed presented and I
understand that that's like a different
way to present news and it was really
hard for some people to wrap their head
around at first and it still is because
I still get a lot of hate but that was
always the main attention where did your
fascination of like the real behind the
scenes the like we're not going for
poised polished press the narrative I
want the back story I want the real
encounters I want people who can give an
honest account of how they got treated
as a human being where did that idea
come from Once people started submitting
stories and I sort of you know got a
handle of the type of people who are
following my account
I I want it more like I became more
interested so it was like you know the
Hollywood insiders the people like I
said that were working in restaurants
working in hotels you know celebrity
spots who would encounter celebrities
all the time so once I started getting
even a little bit of that Insight I was
like this is the way to go like this is
the direction
that you know I prefer the account going
because of course I would get like you
know submissions from fans like I saw my
favorite celebrity at a red carpet
Premiere or at their book signing and
you know those were always like pretty
positive I guess unless like a celebrity
was having a bad day
um but I wasn't interested in that you
know like I was interested in like the
more real stuff like what kind of
tippers like are they good tippers are
celebrities good tippers like I always
post that type of information because
that to me I don't that's interesting to
me human behavior see I love that I've
I've really been a fan of this account
um and hearing that makes it make sense
to me because I do think it's a little
fair game when you sign up for a job
like this I do want to remind anyone
that's listening that everybody has a
slip up everyone has a bad moment but it
is interesting to get
an Insight on the way these people who
do reach like idolatry status
it's it's a little interesting to know
how they treat everybody like that
treating people is a very important
aspect and it doesn't feel gossipy it
just gives me a weird insight into kind
of weeding through the BS and finding
out oh that person's nice to people
because you can't be nice to some you
have to be nice to everybody period I
love that and it's not easy for some
people and I think we also need to
recognize that
um so I do give people Grace and I do
you know I do have empathy I I want to
just also like make that clear like I
know it's gossip and it's you know
celebrities but I do have empathy you
know when I hear certain situations and
how celebrities might have acted in that
situation because you never know what
somebody's going through I know behind
the scenes have you ever had something
come across your desk so to speak
metaphorically where you just thought
this is gonna ruin this person's life I
can't do it oh my God yes all the time
and you know there's a lot of things
that come that I come across that are
litigious that have to do with
celebrities and I pass those off I pass
those off to real reporters real
journalists like I am not trying to like
cosplay being an investigative
journalist like that's not
my intention my intention is to
entertain and build a community
and that's why I love
doing what I do do you have a group of
people that are your trusted sources
where you say this isn't for me but I
feel a responsibility to pass this along
and do you have sort of a
alumni if you will that you turn to yes
so there are I have you know people that
I talk to at a variety of outlets
um real Outlets you know news outlets
entertainment Outlets um that if
something I come across I think it would
be better suited for a page six or a
Daily Mail like I'll pass it off
100 and then there are there are certain
people that I turn to as kind of like a
mentor
um you know that work at different
Publications like do you think this
would be okay to post or like you know
what do you think about if I post this
and I and I value their opinion because
they've been in the business way longer
than I have like this is all new to me
I'm I'm a newbie oh my God this is a new
career a new career for me even so I
need their guidance and I need their
advice and there are people that work in
the industry that are so nice and help
me for nothing like they have nothing to
gain from it
and I've built those relationships over
the past like almost three years and
it's been amazingly helpful to me I love
getting the fly on the wall in sight
into this account that you've built up
that is just so notorious and I don't
mean that in a negative way I mean it in
a positive way like it's not easy to
come up with an idea or have that spark
and actually have it become the brush
fire that it is it's a phenomenon and
may I just add that your book also just
got bought
um and they're gonna make it into a
movie or a show yes they're um HBO Max
bought the rights to the book They're
gonna make it into a one-hour drama
series produced by Greg berlante yep
um so that's so exciting like you know
listen the book is fun like people have
read it in one sitting it's it's meant
to entertain it's meant to like you know
pull back the curtain a little bit and
maybe on fashion but there are like a
lot of you know celebrity encounters as
well but it's also like heavily fashion
focused the book because my background
is in fashion which I probably have
never really like said on the record but
I was just gonna say are we getting a
doomwa exclusive whatever listen I'm not
hiding like I'm not hiding from anyone I
will say like At first the anonymity was
very important to me because I did have
another job while I was doing this and I
did not want my boss to know that I was
spending so much time and effort on
something that I that wasn't my job so
my biggest fear was my I would walk into
work and my boss would show me his phone
and be like is this you is this your
account like I was what did you say
well it never happened that's why I
protected my anonymity like so much in
the beginning but I quit my job
um you know a couple months ago I'm
doing this full-time and the anonymity
is really just because I'm trying to
build a brand like I'm trying to like I
said like create like a new form of
media really I don't want it to be about
me I don't want to be an influencer I've
I would love if someone else could be
the face of this account I don't want to
be an actor I don't want to you know I'd
rather be like The Mastermind behind the
curtain and just like I'm so in tune to
my audience and I'm so in tune to my
followers like that's my strength not
this this is not my strength like I
realize that so would you say that this
account this movie and the making your
book is a little bit of like Devil Wears
Prada meets Wizard of Oz like you are Oz
you're the man behind the curtain well
maybe the Oz part will come in later
because in the in this book it ends in a
very specific period I would say it ends
around December 2020
um January 22 21 so a lot happened in
between then and now
um and you know I think that with the
book yes it shows the craziness
that was going on in my life like at the
Inception of the account and when it
became like so popular and there's also
like a lot of stories like friendships
and like relationships that are in there
that are heavily heavily heavily based
on my real life I think there's a
romance in there that people don't think
is real but it is heavily based on
my life so well I feel a sequel already
in the works because that's a great lead
up and you know I I feel like there's
obviously a lot more to come the stuff
now we're gonna learn about the teeing
up of the explosion of dumois and then I
know we're going to want to hear about
the aftermath by the way is the boss
like a real character is this someone
you really like left is this you know is
this a fictional character or a real
character so the boss in the book her
name is Sasha she is a combination of
God I hope I get in trouble for saying
this she's inspired by real stylists
real celebrity stylists stories I've
heard about real celebrity stylists and
also past bosses I've had so she's a
combination and inspired by both those
things I cannot tell you the amount of
celebrity stylists
or people in the fashion world that I
have truly to the core of my being felt
so uncomfortable around
yes so I guess like that's where the
comparison to Devil Wears Prada comes in
but you know it's not a magazine editor
it's a stylist I guess you know there's
a duality out there in every field in
the world but boy that that that world
is a wild one so thanks for bringing
some light to it all right we have to
take a quick commercial break we'll be
right back
all right welcome back shall we jump
into
uh something you're so familiar with
some stories and some news
yeah let's do it all right I love it
here we go let's get into a story number
one Serena Williams husband Alexis
seemingly Shades Drake over his latest
song and the lyric which refers to him
as a in quotation marks groupie Alexis
went to Twitter with a quote the reason
I stay winning is because I'm Relentless
about being the absolute best at
whatever I do including being the best
groupie for my wife and daughter game
set match thoughts
I mean first of all you know Drake and
Serena dated oh I did not know that well
allegedly
um but yeah I mean I have a a great
sighting of them at a restaurant in
Toronto Soto Soto that's a favorite of
Drake's and yeah I'm pretty sure they
dated very quietly so for him to add a
lyric about her you know
he's pining he's missing her who
wouldn't she's like the goat Hal hath no
scorn oh wait no Hal hath no fury like a
drake scorned
yes I love that I love that you know
he's always in his feelings Drake is
always in his feelings so are we
surprised really I find it I I know he
went after Megan the stallion I just
think that honestly like listen we're
talking about it right and we're talking
about the song
and people are going to want to listen
to it so that's why I feel like I feel
like rappers like especially use that
tactic and it's it's a genius marketing
tactic if you really think about it well
I'm thinking about it now that you've
said it and yeah that we are talking
about it so exactly I guess he made his
point
um all right the next story Rolling
Stone reports on Selena Gomez's very
unique 30th birthday party I didn't know
about this she threw herself a wedding
themed celebration saying I thought I'd
be married by now so I threw myself a
wedding Selena acknowledges all the
lessons she learned in her 20s as she
looks forward to her 30s I mean thoughts
any inside scoop or insights that you've
heard about this particular wedding
themed birthday party well before she
had the birthday party I was hearing
from people that she really really
really wants to be in a serious
relationship
so having this party and thinking about
you know the fact that maybe she's not
married and wanting to be on that path
now it all makes sense you know because
people always ask me who is Selena
dating that is one of the number one
questions I get all the time and I have
to give it to her she is private people
don't know who she's dating she keeps
that on the DL and I give her a lot of
credit because it can't be easy so
um I think it's empowering that she did
this good for her I love it it's a good
manifestation I will say and for sure
whatever is missing in your life give it
to yourself why do you have to wait for
another person to give you the gifts
that you are seeking CR like just feed
yourself feed your soul give yourself
what you want in life and the rest will
follow and and with her documentary I
just have such deep respect for the work
she does was listening to her on Jay
shetty's podcast the other day and it's
like this woman is really doing the work
she is
incredibly insightful about the Journey
of life I mean I would say at 30 years
old she's got the wisdom of someone
twice her age she is you know it's never
really about numbers it's about the
journey I'm glad she can keep her you
know private life private you know we
all I know lots of people speculate on
her love life
um you know and until she's ready to
sort of come out and say I'm single or
I'm with somebody or I'm dating someone
um if she can manage to have that be on
her terms in this world I agree kudos to
her that being said are you single I
love how you slip that in
um well first before I answer that
question I do want to say and anyone
listening who is thinks that they're
like they should be married or they're
at a certain age in their life and
they're like why aren't I why aren't I
married being married does not define
you as a person
either does having children so if you
are in your 20s your 30s or 40s or 50s
and you and you you are looking at
yourself like what's wrong with me why
aren't I married
don't let that get you down I feel like
there's so much focus on that in our
society and it drives me crazy because
that does not define who you are as a
person what's in your heart that defines
who you are as a person and how you
treat others that defines you as a
person what kind of you know you know
daughter sister aunt that's that defines
who you are so
I I feel like we need to take away you
know the emphasis on having to be
married and be in a relationship
um that being said I'm single
um but there is a love interest in the
book
um we still talk I don't know TBD it's
like up in the air it it's not easy uh
you know I'm human just like everyone
else but I like him and he still circles
in the in the universe yes he still
circles in the universe he lives in LA
and I live in New York so that makes it
hard
um but not impossible
well not impossible but he has other
priorities which he's made very very
clear and I'm just not one of them
so I I think I'd need to like you know
move on from it but it's hard because I
like him and it's been
in the book like you know he was there
from the beginning so it's been I've
known him for like almost three years
and
it's just a bummer you know what I mean
when it when things don't work out and
you like someone it winds up being just
a bummer like how else do you describe
it I dated a guy a while ago who I would
literally call a one-way ticket to let
downtown yeah exactly but did you do you
stop like if you're enjoying that
person's company and like also like the
sex is amazing like
so hard to pull away it's so hard I also
I've gotten confused first of all I just
want to agree with you on other hood and
you know not letting a marriage or
children Define you I think when
somebody is slippery and you can't
harness that secure feeling that doesn't
work for me personally me either and it
actually makes me spiral
into like a dark place because you're
constantly questioning yes all of their
actions every second you're questioning
like what are they doing why aren't they
texting me like why didn't they respond
back like it's been an hour like why
aren't they texting me and it's just
like it almost is like not worth it does
he know everything you do it seems like
from what you were saying like he's been
there from the start does he know yes
yes
he's in the industry he's in he's in the
industry he was actually like someone
who was kind of like a mentor to me in
the beginning and helped me with a lot
of things
um see that's a bond I mean this person
really knows like the real you which is
gonna be something very foundational
right but it's like
it's not working out it's not why do I
have to compromise and say like like to
your point like why can't I just be
casual and why can't it just be fun like
that's not what I want it's very hard to
admit admit to yourself and say out loud
that is not what I want it's very hard
when you're in that like situation I'm
telling you I want so little and I still
can't have it be
there's so much elusive unaccountable
Behavior out there and I think for the
little I want my brain is wondering the
same things you just said why aren't you
texting me why do I not know when our
next plan is it's like I'm just like be
able to make a plan plans make people
feel so confident and they know where
they stand and you don't have to do a
lot more than that but you've got to let
people know where they are you got to be
reachable you gotta drop some thoughtful
things that are connective here and
there it's so simple but it is hard to
find it is hard to find it isn't that
such a shame because it isn't that hard
to just text and check in or text and be
like looking forward to that date in a
couple weeks like if I were to make a
date three weeks from now I would have
anxiety from today until that day if if
it was or was not gonna happen do you
know what I mean I just have that like
level of like I guess like trust that I
don't have and like
humanity and Men you know it's like it
it's almost not worth it drew you know
sometimes I'm like is it even worth it
I'll just be alone
I think maybe someone will come along
and I've I am saying this not
hypothetically I'm saying it because
it's what I've personally practiced
which doesn't work for everybody it's
just my journey I have said I am so
happy to be alone someday someone will
come and turn my head and behave in a
way that will help me build trust over
time and I will be open to it
when that occurs and nobody's done that
for me
so far so I haven't
been willing to engage past you know
some simple getting to know each other I
found getting to know them I'm like I
don't know what I'm looking for I
certainly know everything I'm not
looking for and so when they feed into
that and check those boxes of the things
I'm not looking for I just make my way
out of the room and that's that but
that's okay like I think that that's a
healthy way
that's a healthy way to look at it
because why should you compromise you
shouldn't compromise anything that's on
your checklist because then in the end
it's not going to be a good situation
anyway but we often compromise so much
God I I agree and you don't need to
compromise and someone will come along
that brings you out of your shell our
next topic
um this is a funny dovetail
um this is more about spreading the love
around
um Nick Cannon just announced he is
expecting his 11th baby and his friend
Ryan Reynolds was quick to take a job
we're gonna need a bigger bottle which
she added to a retweet of the people
story that shared the news one more kid
and he can make a Cheaper by the Dozen
remake uh thoughts dying to hear your
take on this well our Ryan and Nick
friends are they even friends Ryan
Reynolds and Nick Cannon did do a
commercial together for Ryan's Aviator
gin so okay there we go okay but yeah
Ryan Reynolds is a nice guy and he's
full of humor so wherever he's coming
from I don't assume it's from a
nefarious nasty Place yeah I was I I
mean I've heard also I don't know him
personally I've heard he is a nice guy
as well he he does get a little cheeky
and he does get a little sarcastic so
that's how I took it but I also I don't
know I didn't love it I didn't love it
it didn't sit well with me let the guy
do what he wants everyone gives him so
much for all these kids he's having but
like
who's it hurting
I don't know I just I feel like just let
him procreate as much as he wants if
everyone involved is
okay with the situation then who are we
to say I don't like to judge people for
their life choices so well that is not
the answer I was expecting I don't know
what I expected but you really made me
raise an eyebrow and kind of cool my own
Jets about this because you're right let
him do his thing don't judge huh wow
well thanks for uh changing my tune
about that I didn't even know how I felt
about it but I you have completely you
know Illustrated for me how I should be
thinking about it all right you can take
a quick commercial break we'll be right
back
all right welcome back next story
according to the New York Post Sydney
Sweeney said that she was nervous to
work with Dakota Johnson on their
upcoming superhero movie Madam Webb
because she's so hot Sweeney starring in
the new Marvel movie with Johnson along
with Emma Roberts and Adam Scott the
movie is set in the Spider-Man world and
it will be about The Clairvoyant
character Madam Webb uh
thoughts first of all that cast is
amazing it sounds amazing I'm really
looking forward to this movie I know I a
lot of my followers are so into the
superhero and Marvel universe so I'm
sure I'll be posting a lot about this
movie
um listen like I think that she's
giving with that comment she's giving
Dakota the respect as someone who's been
in the industry longer who's been in you
know many hit movies
um the respect she deserves I I don't
know were people put off by the fact
that she called her hot and didn't
comment on her acting ability I don't
know how they were taking the story what
I thought it did
was immediately put to bed any potential
thoughts feelings rumors
or energy that these girls might be in
competition and as a woman who loves
women and who was so upset when people
would say when we were making Charlie's
Angels that the three of us didn't get
along when we were building some of the
strongest relationships we will ever
have in our lives I just thought you
know what people will see the
consistency and the friendships when
they see it and they can just say
whatever they want I guess I'm going to
trust in the reality of the situation
which is we are sisters and we are truly
bonded and I've always loved women I've
never competed with them
um growing up in the industry you get a
lot of rejection a lot of people get
parts over you and it's ripe with the
energy to be competitive and jealous and
I just thought I will never subscribe to
that it took me a little a while it was
hard as a kid you just don't have the
equipment to sort of know how to get
quickly to the high road but I found my
way and these kind of comments I think
just sort of annihilate any potential
speculation that they had competition I
think way to go Sydney Sweeney who by
the way is the hottest woman also so
it's confident it's bold I love it it's
Sisterhood it's congratulatory it's
supportive it's celebratory all all
women should be doing this for each
other okay that is so interesting that
that was your take because I guess I
have never heard Dakota or Sydney to be
that type of girl that type of
competitive girl that type of caddy girl
so that didn't even enter my mind
because I've never heard that about
either of them if it was to other
actresses that I or actors that I've
heard
um you know things like of that Vain
about maybe I would have thought that
way but that's so interesting that yeah
the way totally they put to bed any any
sort of like conflict on set with that
comment you're right yeah those are
those both of those actresses honestly
like I said have only I've only heard
positive things I love that because I am
such an Uber fan of both of them both
personally and professionally I've had
the pleasure of knowing Dakota in and
around over many decades and Sydney
sweetie came on our show and it was a
while ago it was like before Euphoria 2
came out and
um I think White Lotus had just come out
she was really on the precipice of major
stardom and I was just so in awe of her
and she was nice she was cool she was
down home I liked hearing that she loved
design so much I was heartbroken when
the younger generation was less than
accepting of her family life and where
she comes from and that she has you know
all the appeal to younger hipper cooler
kids but also comes from a family that
is very Americana and you know just is
different than you know I I just I
thought oh oh please don't take this
lovely girl down for where she comes
from that I didn't feel I didn't I I was
that bummed me out because I think she's
a really great person and you know if
she can be ingratiated with everybody
that would make our world a better place
if everybody was like I love this over
here and that over there and we'll find
the common ground let's start you know
stop being so angry about our
differences the acceptance uh she has my
full support she really does as I'm a
huge fan of both Dakota and Sydney and
this is the exact tone women in any
industry should be setting which is I
love that person I think they're hot
can't wait to share the space with them
people fear if they lift someone else
they go down it's the exact opposite you
both rise period now our next story is
something you brought to the table yes
well speaking of celebrity relationships
um you know everyone is like super super
interested in these like rekindling
romances like are Kim Kardashian and
Pete Davidson like are they talking are
they hanging out
um and then another one is Bradley
Cooper and Arena they've been oh but
they're the parents together so of
course they're going to be together I
know but like the pictures that came out
recently like a little PDA a little a
little like hand around the waist to
hand around the shoulder
um and people went crazy for it like I'm
sure like you just said like as a
celebrity you realize like these
Paparazzi pictures
make people spin like when something
like that comes out like the public
starts spinning just from a simple
picture and they could have not even
been thinking twice about it you know
maybe she was about to like fall off the
curb and like her hand went around her
shoulder and the paparazzi got a picture
and now everyone wants to know if
they're back together
um but yeah people are spinning over
these Bradley Cooper Arena pictures and
then him and Pete
um
I have heard I will say
not getting back together no chance
know-how but I think that there's part
of the population that loved them as a
couple and you know we're all hopeless
Romantics I guess at heart which I kind
of love I do love the way she speaks
about him too she's so kind about him
she's always singing his praises and
it's just
so lovely wherever their relationship
goes I think she sets a great tone for
people to learn from and follow which is
you know just because things don't work
out where does the love go it doesn't
have to go away it can transfer into
something else and we never have to stop
being complementary about that person
just because we're not still in a
relationship status I love the way she
just sort of so sweet about him she's
always singing his Praises what about
Pete do you what do you hear about him
well before he started dating him you
know I did hear a lot about how he
conducts himself in relationships I
heard he was a bit of a love bomber yeah
from people who had dated him in the
past which is fine you know like we say
these things and like sometimes I I'm
about to post something like that and
I'm like how is this going to be
received like is it even worth posting
because you know people act like he's I
don't know like murdering kittens
because he's a love bomber do you know
what I mean like fans take this news
like so hard sometimes that it's almost
like not worth talking about but yeah
like I hear he's like a bit of a love
love bomber and that doesn't make him a
bad person oh my God I mean we just
talked about men who are unaccountable
and unavailable and now we're gonna bash
the other side what do we want you know
this is no you can't have it both ways I
I will say that
um every girl that he's dated has done
nothing but talk about how wonderful he
is and I'm sorry but you can't pay
people to say that people don't do
favors that just every woman he's dated
has just talked about oh I see why he
gets all the ladies or oh he's so
wonderful like you know maybe it's too
much too soon for some people but I
everybody says nice things about him and
I've met a lot of people that have
worked with him
um you know from like wardrobe people or
people behind the scenes and everyone is
like he is the loveliest person so I
have a lot of Goodwill towards him and
um it seems like he probably needs
someone who can match the level of love
that he is able to give yeah you know I
think with as far as like his
relationship with Kim Kardashian I do
think that they were really into each
other I think her world was too much for
him
I think it was like a lot for him to
navigate I think he's like really
low-key in a way I mean I know he's like
you know
in movies and on TV and you know a
celebrity but there's a part about him
that you know he's from he still goes
back to his hometown in Staten Island
and you know he loves his mom so much
and he lived in his mom's basement like
he's not like flashy in Hollywood and I
think that maybe that part of her world
was hard for him to live in and that's
just my speculation nobody really told
me that I did hear that he was a little
aggravated with the show and like how he
was mentioned on the show or how he was
tried how they tried to like maybe turn
him into like a storyline I did hear
Rumblings of that but
um
you know I just think their worlds are
too different
I I yeah I think
speaking from experience on this
it is weird when because relationships
have a lot of
pressures or their Stakes involved in
the navigating of them just between the
two people intimately in their world and
when you add on the cafe cafeteria style
of just heaps and heaps and heaps of
you know food and helpings and servings
on top of that from what the public sort
of how they involve themselves and
speculate and put that pressure on it's
a lot and it can become a little
backbreaking and it's almost hard to get
to the root of your own feelings and
intimate experiences and back down to
just those two people alone together
because there's just so much Mania going
on around it and I've you know I've
really not had it to the degree that
like the Kim Kardashians have it
um I I just I I live a different life
um but I have myself experience like wow
I think I like this person but this just
might tip the scales and make me feel
overly committed before I'm ready to and
it can it can be tough you know imagine
anyone who like wants to speculate on
someone's relationship get into the
shoes of what it would feel like if
everyone was speculating on your
relationship put those shoes on and try
to empathize with how hard it is already
to navigate a relationship and then you
want to again load it up load it up load
it up it just gets too heavy sometimes
so it could have been as simple as that
like just it's too much yeah and I think
that because people love them together
so much that you know they're just kind
of trying to manifest like this reunion
and one of the outlets was reporting
that they were having secret rendezvous
at a hotel I don't think it was reliable
I don't think it was true
um but that's just how much everyone
loved them being together which is I
think that's nice like that that we all
feel that way I know about them I was
gonna say I hope they do at the end of
the day take it as a compliment that
people like them both individually so
much that they wanted them to be
together so it could just double your
pleasure as they say in the old Wrigley
spearmint gum world
I mean people were after they broke up
they were going to the restaurant that
he took her to in Staten Island and made
signs that said like R.I.P keep with
like flowers and candles and they put it
outside the restaurant wow and some
somebody that was in Staten Island took
a picture and sent it to me well I
thought that was real actually I thought
that was nice you know I was like people
are really mourning the end of this
relationship well um and that that goes
from so much you know pressure and
speculation into rooting for people so
all the people out there in the world if
you really want something to work work
for a couple please be kind and patient
and give them Grace and it'll be a lot
easier for them because if you hound
their every move it's going to probably
break them at some point wow that just
made me think like me like maybe I
should stop posting about couples I post
a lot of relationship stuff because you
know there is that part of like what I
do that people want the salacia stuff
and I won't post about certain subjects
there's just certain things I will not
post about so I feel like relationships
is kind of like fair game but after this
conversation I'm like oh maybe I gotta
tone it back
it's I it's hard you know I think some
people really take it to heart and they
they just they realize that they want to
run away from something because they
want to go back to something more
intimate and private that's not
speculated on and it just adds a
pressure it's like oh we've gone on a
few dates and everybody assumes we're
now basically getting married and I
can't tell you how many people I've
known in the industry that gave up
before something started because they
couldn't take the pressure of it really
oh yeah we're all in a bit of a risky
business and right there are just
things said and done about everybody in
every town and every co-working
situation and every everything so again
don't listen to the public no comment
decree make yourself clear have Maya
culpas be human apologize speak and say
when something doesn't feel right let's
just all be better communicators and
advocators for ourselves so thank you so
much for this time I really hope we can
do it again are you kidding me like any
time any time like we can care for you a
dream wall
I love that I also feel like I kind of
had like a therapy session like I have a
lot to think about when we hang up I'm
not gonna lie like I have I'm
reconsidering like my relationships what
I post like everything oh my god let's
see thoughtful people don't you know not
thoughtful people don't do that and I I
just would love to play more I I you
know I do think there's such an
attraction
to your world
um you know these things are not going
anywhere anytime soon so your brand is
more fun and more spirited and people
love it so keep doing your thing keep
evolving like I said
um we're all works in progress but I I
like let's do more let's do another
podcast let's do the show I'll keep your
anonymity I'll do it in any way you see
fit okay I mean I appreciate your
support I mean it's wow thank you so
much I'm like speechless I don't even
know what to say thank you well I'm a
huge fan and and I I hope you know that
all of my readers and audience like love
you too as well like your name always
pops up
um when we're talking about like you
know the nicest celebrities or The Not
So Nice celebrities always the nicest
you're always on the nice list and when
people ask me that question like other
reporters or if I'm I'm on someone
else's podcast people love the question
like who do I think the nicest
celebrities are and you're always on
that list and they always agree so just
know that I'm sure you do know your
reputation is like top tier top-notch in
the industry thank you everyone it means
everybody feels me I really love people
and
I just I want everybody to get treated
well that's what they deserve and
nothing less however you know everybody
gets Alley Cat when they get messed with
so I empathize with that too all right
thank you so much uh for doing this and
that is the end of our podcast
um please go ahead and tell anyone you
know you like share in the dumois spirit
the encounter which is really the word I
fell in love with because I think it
sets a tone so if you'd like a Drew's
news encounter or you have a hearing or
a sighting or whatever just share and
spread the word that's how do mois
functions that's how we function by word
of mouth so thank you for listening and
I just have to say we make all of this
for you so take it with you thanks
everybody